- I think July 1st was the
first day of recession.
I think the numbers on GDP's
gotta come out July 28th,
and we'll find out
if it's two quarters
of economy declining, and
then it'll become official,
some economists will say that.
Now, CNN, I don't know if
you saw the article last week
by CNN saying, some experts
are saying we're in recession,
but why is it that it's
eight white economists
that are saying
we're in recession?
- That's... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Saw this article.
- Yeah.
- When comes down to recession,
nobody cares what color you are.
And they said, these economists
are not diverse enough,
there's no African
American economist...
In America, the African
American population is 13%,
but only 3% are economists.
and this percent is this,
but that percent is this.
And I said, look,
in America, 24% of the
population is Hispanic.
But in the NBA, it's
only one Hispanic player.
What a racist
organization the NBA is,
why don't you guys go a
little bit more diverse
and hire some Hispanics?
There is no Iranian
basketball player.
I'm offended that you
guys don't have any
Iranian basketball
players in the NBA.
So you hear comments like
this people are making
to get people
distracted from the fact
that we're in recession,
it's what's happening.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the founder
and CEO of Valuetainment,
host of the PBD
Podcast and author
of "Your Next Five Moves: Master
the Art of Business
Strategy", Patrick Bet-David.
Finally, welcome to
the Rubin Report.
- It's great to be on.
- Good to see you, my friend.
We are both relatively
new Floridians, so I feel
we should start there.
Do you have anything you
wanna tell the people
about life in Florida?
- I gotta tell you.
I lived in LA 20 some years
minus the time in the military.
I lived five years in Dallas,
Texas, which was fantastic.
I kept one of my
companies there,
but then Florida, if
California and Texas could make
a baby, it would be Florida.
Could get the lifestyle,
and you get the taxes, they
kind of leave you alone.
So we're in love
living in Florida.
- So you moved the
company for what was it?
Five years in Dallas?
And then what caused
you to leave Texas?
Because Texas is pretty good.
You ain't paying
the taxes there.
It's a nice
lifestyle over there.
Was it purely weather and
tropical leave related?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
So for me, we were at a
point where we outgrew
the headquarters,
and Valuetainment and the
insurance company were
in the same headquarters,
same office.
And then it was either
I'm gonna sign a lease
of a few years with
Valuetainment in Dallas and kind
of move them to a
different building.
Or if I'm moving, that's
the time to make the move.
So at the time when this
decision was being made,
it was at the beginning
of COVID and my wife
and I, we were looking
at New York because if we're
running a media company,
a media company you
gotta be in a place
where you can recruit executives
from the media company,
you can recruit talent
to wanna live there...
So we said, Greenwich, New
York, great, it's right there,
it's the Mecca, you can
compete, the market's available.
We looked at Tennessee
because the state's taxes.
And then we looked at
potentially going back
to Newport Beach, California,
because media, again, there,
but COVID happened.
Everything kind of
moved away from there.
We always go to Florida.
And then I knew
Valuetainment and the media
company would be a lot
easier to recruit people
to south Florida than any
of the other locations.
So lifestyle was there.
I got four kids now,
10 and 8 and 6, and my
daughter just turned 1.
So we got a family. That's
a younger startup family.
We gotta be in a place
that's supports education,
all of that combined together.
Finally we said south
Florida's place to go.
And then obviously
the rest is history.
- And I have seen the
video of the house
on YouTube and it's not bad.
Let's just say, it's not bad.
- Two bedroom condo.
It's a very nice place.
We like it. We're
very happy with it.
- Yeah.
Two bedroom condo might
be under the house
that you're rocking over
there on the water in Florida.
Absolutely beautiful.
So I know my audience
knows you from the business
side of things and mostly
from the podcast side
of things and we'll get
into some of that stuff.
But can you just tell people
who don't know your bio
a little bit about growing
up in Iran and just some
of the who, how you got to
where you are kind of stuff?
- Born and raised in Iran,
lived there for 10 years
in Tehran, Iran.
During the revolution
with the Shah, I was born
October 18th, '78, four
months later, he was in exile,
they kicked him out.
Then Khomeini showed up.
Then the military was
in shambles because 2000
of his leaders were
reporting to the Shah.
Khomeini got rid of 'em.
Saddam saw that as an
opportunity. He attacked.
Half a million
people got killed.
Six weeks after Khomeini dies...
This is around July
15th of '89, we escape,
I go to Germany with
my mom and my sister.
We lived at a refugee camp
for a year and a half.
And then from Germany,
we came to the States.
I went to Glendale, California.
Right after high school
I joined the army,
went to the 101st Airborne
Division air assault,
and then got out of the army.
I wanted to be a bodybuilder.
I was gonna be the
next Mr. Olympia,
you know, Arnold
Schwartzenegger.
I was gonna win Mr. Olympia,
going to be an actor,
marry a Kennedy and then
one day run for governor.
But then I met a girl named
(indistinct) who worked
at Morgan Stanley Dean Witter,
she told me about Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter, I was 21...
And she said, this is
how I make a living.
It's a great industry.
I started working
on Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter a day before 9/11.
And then I stayed
in the industry.
Seven and a half years
later, I was in Transamerica.
I was a year at the Morgan,
seven and a half
years, Transamerica.
And then October of
'09 started my own
insurance company, PHP.
We grew that from 66 agents
to 20,000 plus agents,
150 offices nationwide, and
then accidentally started
a YouTube channel that
turned into media company,
Valuetainment, and then
obviously the rest is history.
- So I love how you say that
all with just such ease.
I mean, I know you've
told that story...
There's a million stories
within that story.
I know you've said it
a million times before,
but the reason I wanted
you to say it was
because you are as much as
anyone I think I've ever had
on the show, the living,
breathing example of what
the American dream is.
Now, how could that possibly be?
You are a brown
skinned immigrant.
I thought that this is
the most racist place,
I thought we hate people
from the Middle East,
et cetera, et cetera.
How do you do it?
- You know, with
the power of levity.
Let me give you an idea
what I mean by the power
of levity, and the
power of not taking
everything personally
and crying about it.
So I'm in the army, and one
time, one of these soldiers,
private, I'm in boot camp
with these guys and they said,
so where are you from?
I said, I'm from Iran.
He says, what do you
mean you're from Iran?
I said, I'm from Iran. So
how are you in the military?
Aren't you, are
you a US citizen?
I said, no, I got a green card.
How do you get into the
military as a Iranian citizen?
And you're now in our army?
I said, can you
guys keep a secret?
They said, yeah, what's up.
I said, honestly, I'm
kinda like an underground
spy operation right now,
I'm trying to take all the-
(Dave laughs)
And by the way, these
guys believed it.
And it was to the point
where my Sergeant had
to come and talk to me about it.
And we laughed about it.
But obviously there's
some levity to it.
I remember gonna Alabama
one time and the waiter
at Waffle House, we were
on the way to Panama City,
Florida to party for
like at Club La Vela,
and this Panama City waiter's
just looking at me angled,
and he's like, I've never
seen a nose like that before.
I said, this is what you
call a legit qualified nose
from the Middle East, you
guys don't have stuff like
this in America,
we have it in Iran.
I've never met an Iranian
before. I said, I'm an Iranian.
Anyways. Then I go and I start
working at Morgan Stanley.
It's a very interesting
story what happens one time,
I got into the LDS market,
clients who were LDS.
And it's a very
good market to get
into when you're managing money,
you're gonna get into
different kind of markets,
car wash owners, doctors...
One of the markets
I got into was LDS.
And this one business
owner I sat with,
I go into their house,
it's right after 9/11.
And they said, can you tell
us about your background?
I said, sure, born and raised
in Iran, all this stuff.
And I said, now I'm at Morgan
Stanley, managing money
and helping our families.
And she says, look,
we don't mind doing
business with anybody
from Morgan Stanley, but
we would like you to be
somebody else with a background
that we can relate to.
Quite frankly, after what
happened with the 9/11,
we feel a little bit
uncomfortable doing business
with somebody from
the Middle East.
Now, in that situation, I can
say, how dare you say that?
And go cry and
complain about it.
I said, totally understand.
Left, brought back my partner,
they met, they did business.
We split commission. We
were happy with it, done.
Moral of the story is, I
don't care who you are.
If you're a white, black,
Asian, Middle Eastern, tall,
short, fat, skinny,
educated, not educated,
you got a beard, you
don't have a beard,
you have a mustache, you
don't have a mustache...
Everyone's getting judged.
Whether you like it or not.
And the reason why this
is a topic I'm bringing up
is because as much as
everyone's judging us,
we're also judging people.
So if you get to judge others,
why can't they judge you and I?
So the challenge is
how we react to it.
You can go and think
like you are victim.
I cannot believe what he said!
Or you can go prove him wrong.
Maybe that person was right.
Maybe they didn't make
the right decision.
And then maybe 20 years later,
they're sitting their husband
and wife and saying, babe,
that was the guy
that we said no to.
And look at him now, look
how successful he is,
but either way someone's
gonna be right.
So when you're saying
the whole American dream
success story, look,
I'll tell you something
about right now, the
time we're in right now,
there is two camps.
There is the camps that
are like, well, listen,
don't worry, it's
just not a big deal...
It's gonna be a small
market correction.
Like the Dave Ramsey camp.
Real estate's not
gonna really take,
because look at the inventory.
It's not really that high.
And maybe Dave Ramsey's
right, maybe he's not,
but it's gonna be all
right, don't worry about it.
And then there's the camp
that's gonna be like, listen,
I think it's a shitshow.
I think I better pay
attention to what's going on.
What do you mean? You know,
inventory is going up.
Interest rates are going
up. Inflation is going up.
Gas prices are going up.
4th of July cost me
11% more this year
than it did last year.
Making a million dollars
two years ago and you make
it today, it's like
making $600,000 today,
just two years later.
$100,000 dollars, two
years ago, $60,000.
But at the same time,
that can either
produce a lot of fear
for you and you don't move
and you don't do anything.
Or you can look at this
marketplace where fear is high,
you just have to know.
The American dream of the
next great stories are
born during times of crisis.
The American dream is alive.
Anybody and everybody
can go out there and have
their dreams become a
reality, whatever that may be,
but it'll take a lot
of effort and you not
taking things personally.
- So I, that, what
you just said there,
I think has been your main
message that I've been
picking up on for
the last two months,
as the economy's gotten
real weird and so much
craziness with this
administration and everything,
that more than anything else,
there's opportunity
here right now.
Is that something
that you always saw?
Did your parents teach you that?
Is that just from
the immigrant story?
Like where did that idea of,
oh, things are kind of crappy,
but I have a chance within that.
Where'd that come from?
- Right?
So my parents, you got, my mom,
their Bible was the
Communist Manifesto.
I come from a very
strong communistic family
from my mother's
side who escaped
Russia, Baku,
Azerbaijan and they went
to Bandar-e Pahlavi, which
is like a Port Pahlavi
north of Tehran.
And they stayed there,
but their Bible was
Communist Manifesto.
Admiring Stalin and
Lenin, and how they led.
And so my mother's side,
she thought rich
people were greedy.
On my dad's side. He
was an imperialist.
He thought poor
people were lazy.
So I'm completely confused
in the middle here.
I remember I was 14 years old,
I'm in high school and we
start talking about politics,
first time in my life where
actually you wanna know
what's a Democrat and a
Republican, because we didn't
talk about that stuff early
on because my parents got
two divorces in 20
years over politics.
I come home one day
and I'm like, hey Mom,
are we Democrats or
are we Republicans?
And she said, we're Democrats.
I said, okay, cool.
I said, can you tell
me why we're Democrats?
She says, yeah, because
Democrats are for the poor
and Republicans
are for the rich.
I said, Mom, when I grow up,
I wanna be a Republican one day.
She's like, what do
you mean one day?
I said, I don't wanna
be rich one day,
but I hate being broke.
I hate I wanna do
something about my life
that I have going on.
But in regards to fear,
my dad worked at a 99 cents
stores his entire life.
My dad was worried,
so he wanted me to stay in
the military for 20 years.
And that was the safe route.
My dad's always been the
very safe guy who worked 80
hours a week, always
been a worker.
My mother was very paranoid
who just didn't want me
to become rich and
successful because those are
the people she
despised the most.
But when I got out
of the military, I
had a mentor of mine,
Robbie, who
recommended me a book
called "How to Master the Art
of Selling" by Tom Hopkins.
I'm working at
Valley Total Fitness.
And my sister recommended me
"How to Win Friends
and Influence People"
by Bill Carnegie.
I read those books, Dave,
and I gotta tell you,
2000 books later, I
could not believe all
this information is
in these $10 books,
$8 books, $15 books.
I got obsessed, the stuff
I learned from there,
I applied to my business.
And then obviously the rest
is, it is what it is today.
- Do you consider
yourself political?
'Cause it's kind of funny, when
I listen to you, it's like,
the way you talk
about politics is sort
of seemingly an extension
of the way you talk
about business and money.
Like, you don't strike
me as purely political.
I mean that as a
compliment actually,
like you have a lot
of political insight,
but to me it's
usually connected back
to what you're talking about
on a business side of things.
- I would say I am
pro-capitalist and
extremely aware
of everything that's
going on around me.
Because if you're not,
we become naive and
oblivious to the conditions.
And then sometimes you vote
thinking it's the right
choice and then two years
later you realize 85%
of Americans are not
happy about the economy,
yet 81 million people voted
for this two years ago.
And a lot of them that voted,
they would like their vote back.
And it's not because of its,
you know, who Joe Biden is.
I'm sure he's a great
father and a husband.
That's none of my business.
That's his personal life.
I don't care how he's
running his marriage.
That's none of my business.
I didn't care what Trump
did with his personal life
and all this stuff that you saw
with Bush and the RV
and grabbing this,
that stuff is to you.
You wanna party that way?
All to you. I wanna see what
kind of policies you're making.
So when you do your
taxes the first time
when you make real money
and you cut the biggest
check you've ever cut.
And I was in my mid
to late twenties,
I'm sitting there saying, okay,
where is this money going to?
And you're sitting
there saying, well,
this goes to taxes.
No, and I get that, but where
is this actually going to,
like, what are you gonna
do with this $100,000
dollars you got this year?
What are we gonna do? Is
that gonna be the road?
Is that the exit sign?
Is that the building?
Is that the public?
Where's it going?
And what portion
of that am I using?
And what portion am I
giving that I'll never use?
And is it a responsible way
they're spending this money?
And so then you start
asking yourself,
would we be better putting
that money in taxes
and allowing government
employees to do better
with that money?
Or is that money better
being put into the private
market of those who know
how to do good things
with that money that'll
benefit everybody better?
And then you start saying,
what is this all about?
So then that kind of gets
you to the next level
and the next level.
So for me, it started
with business.
Then I noticed how policies
can affect your business,
regulation, taxes,
all that stuff.
Then it went deeper,
deeper, even I said, no,
you gotta pay attention to all
this stuff that's going on.
- Were you shocked after
20 plus years in LA, then
you go to Texas where
there's no income tax?
Now you're in Florida where
there's no income tax.
I mean, to me,
I don't wanna say this out
loud 'cause I don't wanna
give them any ideas,
but it's like,
I would've paid an
entry tax to get here.
I truly would've.
If they would've said,
Dave, you gotta
pay 50 grand to get
into this state because
we've done it right
and we're trying to keep you
freaks from Cali outta here,
I would've done it.
I think it's actually probably
a worthy thing to look
into when you're bringing
in all of these new people.
But the fact, the simple
fact is, I didn't move here
for taxes, but
now I'm like, wow.
I also have all more
money than I had.
Even if the money isn't
worth as much as it used to,
used to be.
- Yeah. I mean,
listen, what people...
Sometimes when you are
in a bad relationship,
you don't know until you
have another relationship.
Oh my God, what
was that all about?
This is like unbelievable,
like 180, but sometimes
you need to be
in a bad relationship
to know and value
a great relationship.
Sometimes you need a
bad friend to realize
what a great friend is.
Sometimes you need a crisis
to know what life is like
when you're at peace.
Sometimes you need to
go through a dark time
to be reminded of what it's
like when there's light.
Living in California
right now... Look,
here's how it works.
If I was governor DeSantis
and you've had many,
many interactions with them...
If I was governor DeSantis
and somebody said, well,
I don't like what
you're doing with this.
you're doing with that.
I don't like what you're doing.
I don't like these masks,
and there's this stuff
you're doing with,
don't say gay bill
and stuff you do
with Disney and the stuff you
do with taxes and there's...
I don't like the way you
handle vaccine, all this stuff.
I would say, look, if these
seven things are important,
if you like high taxes,
if you want somebody to
make decisions for you,
if you want all of this stuff,
I will buy a one way ticket
for you to move to California.
I'd be pushing people out
of Florida who don't like
the policies that's being built.
At the same time,
I would also say,
if you're watching this
and you like the following
five things, this is
what we do in Florida.
This is the perfect
home for you.
So like right now,
DeSantis came out and
called him out yesterday.
Or you saw that
over the weekend.
Newsom's trying to
call out DeSantis.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- And he said, wow,
lemme tell you Florida,
if you stand up
on Florida, you should
stand up for yourself.
I believe in freedom of
this and freedom to be heard
and freedom to be...
No you don't. No you don't.
You don't believe that stuff.
So a DeSantis in Florida,
you don't like what
we do in Florida?
Go to California.
I think more states,
because if you think
about the one state
that doesn't matter when
it comes down to elections,
what is the one state
definitely doesn't matter
when it comes down to elections?
- Cali.
- California. Yeah.
Okay. So guess what?
Send everybody who wants
high taxes to California,
send everybody who wants
entitlements to California.
If you love it so much,
here's the one way ticket,
go to California and then
everybody else that wants
the job creators like you
and I, come on down here.
- Yeah.
And not only that,
but you can have your
eight month abortions
and you can have your
genitals chopped off or added
or whatever it might be.
It's a bizarre situation.
So you move these companies
and you bring your,
all the people that
are working for you...
What about just sort of
spiritually for everybody?
'Cause I know for my guys,
just every everybody's
life is better.
And putting aside finances,
that it's not just about that,
just the quality of life.
- So spiritually you're saying,
what do you mean by spiritually?
- Just the day to day when
you're seeing these people
and how are their lives
improved by moving into a place.
- Here?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I mean, listen, when
I was moving to Texas, we,
it took us three years.
I was selling Texas
for three years
before we moved to Texas.
My wife is from Texas.
She was born and raised
in Houston, lived
there for 21 years and she
did not wanna go to Texas.
So I sold Texas, Texas, Texas.
Every time an article would come
out about Texas,
I would sell it,
until eventually we moved.
And I knew a few things
that goes as family,
you're gonna miss family.
You're gonna miss
knowing the freeways.
the church you go to.
You're gonna miss the
Starbucks you go to.
You're gonna miss the gym
you go to and the quick
routine that you follow, all
of these routines, you miss,
what you do on Sundays,
all those things...
And then eventually
three, six months later,
people in Texas are like,
I don't miss any of that
stuff in California.
And if I need to take a flight,
I'll just get on a flight,
go to California for a
weekend and I'll come back
on a flight.
It's easy to go.
Then you come to Florida
and you start seeing
what you are able to do here
in Florida with the lifestyle,
with the different things
that it offers and go, okay,
what are the
downfalls of Florida?
Iguanas.
There's gonna be
Iguanas here. Okay.
If you live in Orlando and you
live by like a little pond,
there's probably an
alligator in there.
Okay.
If you live by the water,
like where you live
or where I live,
you're probably not
dealing with alligators
or crocodiles that
are gonna be there.
If you're on the inside. Sure.
Are you gonna get
weather storms? Yes.
Every state has something
that you're not gonna
be happy with.
California's gonna
be earthquake.
Texas is gonna be
tornadoes, blizzards.
Florida's gonna be
storm or hurricanes.
No matter where,
you're gonna have that.
But on a golf score, if you
market on 20 different things,
good luck trying
to beat Florida.
- It's funny, in California
it was like raining
fire half of the year.
And then I moved
here and people said,
"But it's so hot in the summer."
And I'm like, it was
literally raining fire.
There were ashes being dumped
on my house every other week.
All right.
So let's move on to
some of your sort of nuts
and bolt stuff 'cause
we talked a little
bit about economy.
A couple weeks ago you had
a video out that I saw,
where I think you said, but
correct me if I'm wrong,
that you said that
we would officially,
or they would officially
announce a recession,
I think you said by July 15th.
It seems to me they've
already kind of admitted it.
Yellen has, you probably saw
the video where she said,
well, we're probably in
one, but we're hopeful.
And then they all
kind of admitted it.
Well, I guess, A, do you
think we are, I mean,
I think technically
we are in a recession,
but do you think
they will admit it?
And how do you feel about July
15th? Middle of the month?
I mean, are we there?
- I think July 1st was the
first day of recession.
I think the numbers on
GDP's gotta come out July 28
and we'll find out
if it's two quarters
of economy declining and
then it'll become official
and some economists
will say that.
Now, CNN, I don't know if
you saw the article last week
by CNN saying, some experts
are saying we're in recession,
but why is it that it's
eight white economists
that are saying we're recession?
- That's... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Saw this article.
- Yeah.
- When comes down to recession,
nobody cares what color you are.
And they said, these economists
are not diverse enough,
there's no African
American economists.
In America the African
American population is 13%,
but only 3% are economists.
And this percent is this,
but that percent is this.
And I said, look,
in America, 24% of the
population is Hispanic.
But in the NBA, it's
only one Hispanic player.
What a racist
organization the NBA is,
why don't you guys go a
little bit more diverse
and have hire some Hispanics?
There is no Iranian
basketball player.
I'm offended that you
guys don't have any
Iranian basketball
players in the NBA.
So you hear comments like
this people are making
to get people
distracted from the fact
that we're in recession,
it's what's happening.
Now, the question becomes,
how ugly can it get?
And, you know, how many
people will be prepared
for and what
policies the current
administration will come?
My hopes is they
don't do one thing.
And the one thing I
hope they don't do,
'cause it's gonna happen,
when Lehman Brothers,
when AIG, when all
these companies are going
through what they went
through in '07, '08, '09.
When we remember
what happened there,
those stories are gonna come up,
when some banks are
not gonna make it,
you're gonna hear
some stories of some
of these companies that are
multi-multibillion
auto companies.
They're not gonna make it.
And they're gonna
need to be bailed out.
I just hope, Dave, they
don't go the bailout model,
because if they go
to bailout model,
what the bailout model
does is it just delays
the headache for 10 more years,
it delays the headache
for 10 more years,
it keeps delaying it versus
let's just go through it.
And here's what's gonna
happen with the economy
if we go through it.
So interest rates,
right now, 5.7%,
which means you would've bought
a house eight months ago,
your rates would've
been 3%, 2.5%,
right now it's 5.7%. Here's
what people don't realize.
If you go back from today,
let's just say go all
the way back to 1970.
Do you know from 2008
prior, from 2008 and prior,
like 1970 to 2008, do you
know the interest rates
have never been at 5.7%?
It's always above 5.7%.
Let me say this one more time,
from '08 and prior to '70,
rates have always been 6.5%,
7.5%, 8.5%, 9.5%.
In '81, under
Carter, was at 18.5%.
Okay. But that was pretty bad.
Now, let's go worst
case scenario.
Let's go best case scenario.
And you decide where you
wanna manage your level
of risk tolerance.
Worst case scenario, we're
gonna hit 19% in interest rates.
What's the likelihood of
that happening? Less than 5%.
Okay. But that's 19%.
That's worst case. What's
the best case scenario?
We end up around 7%, 7.5% and
we stay there for a few years.
Okay. We go to 7%, 7.5%.
Maybe we go up and hit 10
points, which we probably will.
And then we come back down
and level off or around 7%
to 8%, which is fine.
If we stay at 7% to 8% for a
decade, give or take, a decade,
And we're kind of like,
well, I've got a good rate.
What rate did you get? 7.1%.
Fine.
But now we're going
back to being fiscally
responsible instead of
keeping these interest rates
at zero, and you're
getting loans at 2.5%,
which is all fake money
and it's not the real way
of doing it.
So yes, we're in recession,
but I'm almost leaning
towards the administration
doing nothing.
Now the only thing
I would recommend
if the administration wanted
to do something like this,
who does the current
administration need
the most today?
Well, a story came out
talking about the fact
that companies now
are rescinding offers.
How often do you even
read an article like that?
That means Twitter gave you
a job offer for 100,000,
with $50,000 of bonuses
with 401k, all this stuff,
you get started on the 19th.
And they say to you a
week later after you put
in your two week notice, we're
rescinding that job offer.
Okay? Zuckerberg is
wanting to fire people.
He's doing the right thing.
Tesla's firing people.
A bunch of company
are letting people go
and that's gonna
be taking place.
Now, if that happens and a
lot of people lose their jobs,
economy is gonna take a hit.
Crime's gonna go up.
A lot of scary things
could happen if economy
gets that bad.
The one thing Biden and
their administration
could potentially do is,
and Dave, you tell me
what you think about this.
What if they said, hey,
you got these five employees
you could hire this year
at 50 grand a pop,
let's just pick the
number 50 a pop.
5 times 50.
If you hire five employees,
you give 'em a job,
Mr. Employer, Mr.
Small business owner,
which is 49% of America,
49% of all the jobs are
small business owners.
If you give those five
people $50,000 a year jobs,
we'll give you tax
credit on half of it.
Which means what?
- It means I hire
fire people overnight.
- That's what I would do.
- Yep.
- So now small business
owners are like, listen,
John, come on 50k,
25,000 auto tax credit.
Come on.
So that way the employer wins,
the employee wins and
the administration wins.
Those are the types of things
that administration can do.
Not the PPP loan, not
free money, not a UBI. No.
Let's kind of work.
Put it on me, put
it on the employee,
put it on the government.
Let's work together the
next two, three years,
'cause it's gonna get ugly.
- So I can hear loudly, through
the pipes of the internet,
all of the people
watching this going,
Patrick, you just
made sense there.
But the problem is that
the Democrats are in charge
and that there is basically
a controlled demolition
of our economy.
One of the things that I
talk about on the show a lot
is I try not to judge
people's motives,
but it seems almost
impossible for me to believe
that this is not intentional.
That the inflation stuff
is not intentional.
The printing of money
Everything that they
have done has been
designed specific,
everything with energy,
specifically designed
to destroy the economy.
So of course what you just
said there makes sense.
Like anything,
literally anything,
some tax relief
for people, fine,
but they won't do any of
it because it is by design.
Do you buy that theory?
- Let's play that part.
Let's say is by design.
I hope it is, great.
Do it by design.
Do it by, I'm totally okay
with you doing it by design.
Here's why.
Because they think majority
of the American people
are dummies and they're not.
Let's not expect that
everybody's brilliant.
No, we're naive
if we think that.
Let's say 40% of people
are not gonna pay attention
to anything and they're
gonna fall for that.
You're right. It's
the rich man's fault.
Let's tax the billionaires.
It's not gonna solve anything.
Right? But if that's their
card, it'll backfire.
Why? Let's unpack that.
So go with defund the police,
what a great marketing campaign,
and the Republicans
were so worried.
Look at these. I can't
believe they were saying this.
Let 'em say it because
their own people are gonna
turn against them.
Six months later,
the hell you talking
about defund the police?
Democrats are saying
it to Democrats.
I voted for you. I don't want
you to defund the police.
Well, we never said it.
It was really the Republicans.
No, no you said it.
You said this. This
is not a good idea.
So watch this.
This whole concept where
many people on the left
were saying, companies,
corporations,
you should let people
work from home.
Oh, really? Yes.
You should let people work
from home. No problem.
Who said that? Liberal governors
from left leaning states.
Okay. They said that.
Sounded like a very good idea.
Like you're supporting so
many people on your own side.
No, no.
Here's what you did when
you said you should be able
to let them work from home.
The people said, oh,
so you need to
tell me I can work
for IBM and work from home?
Yes, no problem,
New York, I'm moving
to Florida and I'll work from...
New York lost 21 billion
of tax revenue last year.
So even though, Dave, they're
doing it intentionally,
if they are, majority
of America's gonna fall
for the tactics and
they're gonna say, yeah,
I'm kind of not with you.
I'm stepping away from
you. And I'll flip.
- How do you think the
blue states get out of it?
I mean, I know we could
sit here all day talking
about how great Florida it is.
And I think people get that.
But for the states like New
York, so you lose $21 billion,
California, lost
around 300,000 people.
I think it's even more
than that at this point.
- Yeah.
- All the tax money
that comes with that.
And it's not just that, it's
the type of people that leave.
It's people that are good
community members that care
that are honest, that work hard.
Those are the people
that are fleeing.
What do you think happens
to the blue states?
Like is there a bottom
to that hole, basically?
Is there a rock bottom there
or is it just a free fall now?
- So you see, the
people like yourself,
Dave, how many states you
think would love to have you?
Every state would
love to have you.
Think about how many countries
would love to have us,
think about it.
Let's go live in,
pick a country,
Canada, let let's
go live in Panama.
2.3% unemployment, low
unemployment, but 3%...
Let's go live in France.
Let's go anywhere.
We're gonna bring value
to wherever we move to.
The problem with the blue
states, people is the following.
They're forcing people
like you and I out.
The challenge that happens
when you push people like
us out, you may be only
left with people that were
relying on the people that
were creating the economy.
Argentina right now, I
think some 11 million people
work to take care of
the 8 million people
that are not working.
That system doesn't work.
- Wow.
- Okay. So what do
people eventually do?
They eventually leave.
Now, watch what happened to
Columbia with the new guy
they brought in?
Do people realize who
this guy was before? Yeah.
What philosophies
does he bring in?
Same thing that Venezuela
did with Maduro, same thing
that Cuba did, Columbia
is gonna be next
Venezuela and Cuba that's
taking place right now.
So unfortunately, certain
decisions that is made
policies have
consequences and dates.
Some of them longer than others.
Detroit was the richest city
per capita in the
world, in the world.
In the world.
Like, rich people would go
to Detroit to go to parties.
Like if you lived in
Detroit, you like,
now I'm living in Dearborn.
Oh my God, you
guys are rich guy.
Have you been to Detroit lately?
Have you seen what's going on?
- Oh. I, well, a
couple years ago.
And it is a, I mean,
it looks like a
third world country.
You go into those suburbs
with those houses...
It looks like-
- Yeah.
So some of these bad policies,
I think it's such negative
effects on the economy
of that state, that it may
take decades and decades
to recover, unfortunately.
- But I mean, do you think
they have any chance,
like what would
be the turnaround?
Is it just that they
have to then, okay,
let's basically vote Republican,
get some sane person in,
like what is the
mechanism that would exist
to turn it around?
- So, I'm a data guy.
I love hiring analysts.
So for example, I, we
can have a gun problem
with 50 analysts in a room.
And if I can work with
the FBI and the government
to get all the data,
we can figure out what's
the main marker that caused
the most mass shooting.
And instead of
trying to band this,
and we're spending so
much time with this,
just go watch the movie
"Moneyball," and he hacks,
this guy named Billy
being and get all the data
and we'll realize, you thought
home runs were important,
no one cares, home runs is
not how you go to the top
on base percentage.
We can get data. So
let's go to the states.
So if we wanna find out a
guy to win in California,
let's use that as a case
study, because we are very,
we have an affinity
in California.
Okay. So put the 20 policies
down to win in California.
Guns, second amendment. Okay.
LGBTQ, taxes, health
insurance. I don't know.
Just put all those
policies down.
And in which one of the
policies is economy driven,
which one of them is social,
where a straight up Larry
Elder is not gonna win
in California today.
Right?
Where you need a
bit of a hybrid guy,
not an Arnold who
was eventually fully,
became pretty much a rhino.
He was not necessarily
a Republican.
He went, flipped
on the other side.
So you get somebody like, that
maybe (indistinct) or maybe
some of these guys that are
willing to stay fiscally
on the right.
If they can find a candidate,
like almost like a
Peter Thiel, okay.
A guy like a Peter Thiel,
who made 6 billion off
of his Roth IRA because he
understands laws and tax code.
You bring a guy like,
they're not gonna get
Peter Thiel, by the way,
I know it's this thing.
Like a guy like him,
he'll never do it, but...
- I don't think
they're gonna get him
on the Roth IRA thing either.
He's not gonna run for
governor that's for sure.
But I don't think they're
gonna get him on that either.
- But if California
understood what they had
with Peter Thiel, like, are you,
do you realize who Pete,
who you lost with Pete,
everybody worries
about who they lost.
You lost Peter Thiel.
You could have had Peter
Thiel to help your state out.
Like how do you not use the
talent pool that you have
in your state?
So, but if they got a guy
like Peter Thiel, smart,
understands economy,
so he is socially,
he can be sitting there
saying, well, I can work here,
I can work here, I
can work there...
But if you throw
those data points out,
you'll be able to figure
out who can run for that.
And then you've gotta
find somebody that matches
those six points that they
can sell to that state.
'Cause California's a
little bit more complicated
than other states to find
a real candidate that has
a chance of winning.
- So let's talk about
your book for a second.
So "Your Next Five
Moves", you've well,
you've been kind of hitting
on all the moves in a way
here in the time that
we've been talking,
what's kind of next for you?
Like what are some of the
next moves you're looking
at right now?
- So, this is going live. Okay.
So I just had a massive
exit that I went through.
A very nice exit that
we just have with.
- Congratulations.
- Great partnership.
Thank you.
And for us, we're very excited
about the insurance company.
It's grown from where it
was at 66 agents to today.
What we built, that's
an exciting thing
that we're going
through in the process.
We're very, very
excited about it.
But for me, I look
at it right now
with the marketplace and media.
I think the next 20 years,
I believe in 20 year runs,
I got two more 20 year
runs, God willing.
The next 20 year run is gonna
be purely on the media side.
The messaging of capitalism
is what we're gonna be
leading with when it
comes down to business.
And I think that part of the
message with capitalism is,
it's not Fox news, right?
It's not CNN, left.
It's people on the
left, right, middle,
any angle you look at,
everybody wants to figure
out a way how to get
better in business.
You can be a Democrat and
still be a capitalist.
You can be a Republican
and still be a capitalist.
So our vision is to tell
the story of capitalism
with the best stories
that we can find,
whether it's through movies,
documentaries, shows,
our own OTT, our original series
that we produce
ourselves, comedy...
We're recruiting a lot
of comedians right now.
of podcasters right now
that will bring in here.
A close friend of
yours, Jedediah Bila
just got to talk with us.
She moved here from New
York and we're looking
for many more.
I'm currently in one of the
buildings I just bought.
You came to this building,
we did the podcast,
it was in a bank vault.
We have another
building that we own
that we're gonna create a
live show where you can do
your live podcast with 200
people sitting in front
of you and security, sheriff,
their protection, safety.
And you're talking
to your guest.
Let's just say, you're
doing something with whoever
your guest is, 200
people are sitting there,
they're buying
tickets to come here.
So we're taking a
complete different angle
of where we're going next.
But I think the next 20
years, media is wide open.
You just saw MSNBC as moving
away from Rachel Maddow.
You just saw CNN plus
spend 300 million and all
they could get is
10,000 active listeners.
They took a Wallace away
from Fox and they shut
the deal down and they
spent three, not a spend,
let me say the word better,
they wasted $300 million,
America's sitting there saying,
where do I get my
news from today?
Everyone's curious,
you're seeing a great job
Daily Wire, Ben Shapiro
on their campus doing,
you're seeing a complete
different angle,
a Bar Stool Sports is going
and they're entertaining.
There's so many different
ways of doing it,
but I think the opportunity's
wide open for the media side.
And that's what we plan
on doing next 20 years.
- Patrick, you'll love this,
speaking of the 300
million that CNN pissed
away on that thing.
You know how much money I
have spent in the history
of my show, the history
of the Rubin Report,
on advertising?
Guess how much.
- How much? Wow.
We're in the same camp.
- I've never spent a dime. Yeah.
- But here's the thing though.
Here's the thing though.
So that validates
that your voice,
there's millions on top of
millions, not even millions,
there's tens of millions
of people that wanna
hear from you.
Okay?
There there's a market that
if your message is sincere,
if you are straight up,
if you're willing to talk
and call out your own side,
any sides and you're
receptive to whatever
feedback they're gonna give
you, you're willing to evolve,
just like all of
us are evolving...
Some of our opinions
are changing.
You went from an organization
you were part of before,
where it was seen,
like being in one place
and then you have a meeting
with Larry Elder and
then boom, you're like,
oh my God, this
kind of makes sense.
The fact that you are
showing being open minded,
that's inspiring other
people to say, well,
if Dave can set aside his
ego and he can be, man,
what the hell am I?
I keep getting in my own way.
So your level of people
relate to your authenticity
and they're attracted to it.
And Dave, it's very,
very hard to find authentic
voices like yours.
So I am not surprised you're
kicking ass without having
to spend a single penny.
- Well, likewise, my friend,
and that actually gets me
back to something that you hit
a few minutes ago.
It's sort of this idea
of selling capitalism.
So in my last book,
I wrote a chapter on be
a capitalist in essence.
And when I was writing it,
I had a researcher that
was helping me and we were
diving into it.
And I was like, man,
some of this basic
stuff about capitalism,
about why the free market
works, about what it does
for you sort of spiritually
and that you have
some autonomy over your
life, et cetera, et cetera...
Is it ironic to you that
the capitalists have
not sold capitalism well?
It seems like a sell
job on capitalism
that was the failure.
It wasn't the system, it
was the marketing, I guess.
- Well, listen, look,
everything is in the
way you tell stories,
think about how
pro-abortion didn't work.
Who wants to pro-abort?
Pro-choice, you change the
word, same exact thing,
look what happens to it?
There's nothing more powerful
than pro-life, I'm pro-life.
What a great name,
phrase, pro-life, right?
So market, Make
America Great Again,
it's a pro-life message.
I'm with her.
I don't understand
that. But Dream Obama.
Wow. That wording is like dream.
Obama's gonna do something.
That is exciting.
So in real estate,
many years ago,
when you think
about in America, what
is the American dream?
If you ask the average
person right now,
we do like a street team,
you and I go to New York,
I go to Boston and we meet
up later on tonight,
you go ask people in streets
of New York, you guys,
I go ask people in
streets of Boston.
What is the American dream?
They'll say home ownership.
Who told you it's
home ownership?
Well, it's a marketing
genius years ago,
when they notice more people
are renting than buying...
And they said, wait a minute,
guys, we gotta make money.
People don't start to realize
it doesn't make any sense
to buy a house like today.
It doesn't make any sense
to buy a house right now,
it's better to rent
than buy a house.
What do we do? We gotta
figure something out.
So marketing genius said, look,
why do immigrants
come to America?
They come to America
for the American dream.
What if we're able
to convince all
of America that the
American dream starts
with home ownership?
How do we do that?
I don't care what company
you're a part of, in this topic,
we all gotta be
on the same page.
Everybody that spends
every advertising dollar
when it comes down
to American dream,
we all do it the same way.
What do you mean?
Here's how a commercial
should sound like: babe,
I'd love one day for us to
live the American dream.
What are you talking about?
How much longer do
we need to rent?
We came to America so
we can own our own home.
That's the American dream.
And you see the commercial.
They open the keys in the door.
They go inside, wife kisses
the husband and says,
oh my God, it feels so amazing
living the American dream.
Boom. Everybody bought a house.
Why? It's the flipping
American dream.
Capitalists suck at telling
the story of capitalism.
And do you know why?
I'll tell you why.
A big part of it,
have you noticed how Jeff Bezos
has grown some brass lately?
I don't know if you've
noticed that on that.
- Yeah.
Well he seems like he's doing
a little bit of a shift,
although he's still
doing some evil stuff
with Washington Post, but I'll
give him a little something.
Okay.
- But why do you think
though? Why do you think?
Let's actually unpack that. Why?
Why is he talk?
What are you doing
twice in three months,
you call out Biden on Twitter?
What are you doing?
You voted for this guy.
So why is he doing that?
There's only one
way I can speculate.
Who's the guy that gets
more attention than he does?
Who gets more attention
than he does that's as rich
as he is?
- Elon, Elon.
- Well, Elon.
- Yeah.
- I'm here to tell
you my speculation.
Elon Musk is indirectly
training Bezos to grow some,
and Bezos start to finally
realize, I'm a freaking badass.
What the hell am I doing
being so afraid of walking
on eggshells around everybody?
I'm one of the richest
guys in the world,
if I'm not the richest.
So capitalists are
afraid for others
to know they're successful.
First of all, screw the
people that are bashing
you for you being successful.
There's the other 50% of
America that has wanted
to listen to the
American dream stories
because they also
wanna live their dream.
So inspire them. Don't
lose your backbone.
Don't go tell the story
of how you did it.
Go tell 'em how hard it was.
Go tell 'em the
sleepless nights.
Go tell 'em the amount
of time you slept
under your office desk.
You, your pillow was the floor.
You're like just sitting
there, getting up,
coding in the morning.
Tell those stories because
people wanna know that.
And then eventually more
people are gonna sit
there and say, man,
what the hell am I like?
Why do I bash so
many rich people?
I'm sick and tired
of being broke.
I wanna make some money.
So I think capitalists
have to stop apologizing
for being successful, and
just tell him the way you did
it and be okay that
you're gonna get hate.
You're supposed to get
hate. You're a winner.
Winners get all the hate.
Stop, like being confused
that everybody's supposed
to like you when you win.
People don't like a winner.
Like Michael Jordan was
most hated player when he
was winning all the time.
LeBron was hated.
Kobe was hated.
Stephen Curry's currently hated.
Draymond Green is hated.
But we love winners.
We admire them.
So I think sometimes capitalists
have lost their backbone.
I'm glad to see...
I'm not a WaPo fan,
but I'm glad to see that
even a Bezos is willing
to kind of grow
some and say, hey,
and maybe it's the girl
that's doing it to him,
that's saying, listen, you're
a badass, say something.
You gotta say something.
You're a pretty big
badass. Say something.
So I'm kind of feeling like
we're seeing the transition.
I may be wrong, but I'm
seeing that transition,
which is good news.
- Well, for the record,
I think LeBron with the
flopping and the China stuff
maybe is deserving.
Kobe, not so much,
Jordan, not so much.
They killed everybody.
But it's interesting that you
said the thing about Elon.
'Cause I think you're right.
He's mapping something.
That's one of the things
I've been saying on the show
for months now.
Maybe he's mapping it
for Bezos, but I think
he's mapping it for everybody.
Because even if he's
the world's richest man,
he's still just one guy,
and he's saying, hey,
I will not bow because you
hear this all the time,
well I'm gonna say what I
want when I've got FU money,
and I'm sure Patrick, you
probably know way more
of the billionaire
class than I do.
They often don't. Tiel does.
He's one of the guys that will
do the F you to everybody.
But I think what happens
is they start going, oh,
now I have all these employees.
I have all these houses. I have
all these responsibilities.
So they become more quiet
than they were before.
And Elon I think is
now mapping, hey,
get out there and do something.
Although I will say, as we're
recording this right now,
he's gone quiet on
Twitter for a little bit.
I'm not exactly sure
what's going on there.
So something weird
might be brewing.
- And maybe the
closing of the deal,
then he is told by the
lawyers on the other side
that you have to stay quiet
until the deal closes.
And I went through the
process myself on a much,
much smaller deal,
but it's still a
multi-multi-nine-figure-deal.
And you are told by
lawyers to stay quiet.
So if that could be some
of the things that's being
scored away, like kind
of putting it together
that both lawyers are saying,
you can't say
anything on Twitter.
- So the mapping though,
this general idea of like
do something for yourself,
that's sort of it more
than anything else,
doesn't matter if
you rich or poor.
- Yeah. You know what's
the best thing about that?
It's the first person
that does it makes it okay
for the other guys to do it.
So Elon is mapping it out
for Bezos and others to say,
here, you can be
super successful.
You can say what you
wanna say in Twitter.
And you can piss people
off and that's okay.
It's supposed to be that way.
Stop being so soft,
worried about what others
are gonna say about you.
I got a lot of employees
and some of them don't agree
with me politically, but
you know what happened?
I'll stop.
And I said, tell me
how you feel that,
why you feel that way?
Well, Patrick, the other
thing on the podcast, he said,
X, Y, Z, I disagree with you.
Really, tell me why,
blah blah blah. Okay.
That's a good point. Okay.
Fair enough.
This is why I said this.
I never thought
about that before.
Well, why don't we keep
continuing this conversation,
see where it goes
six months from now?
Fair enough.
So that's what's gonna
happen if your employees
are against you or they don't
agree what you have to say,
but the opposite of you
standing there and not
saying anything and
not taking a stand.
Well, then that's
typically not the qualities
of a leader we admire.
Bezos and Musk have the
same amount of net worth.
Bezos and Musk don't
have the same amount
of influence and following.
Elon has 100 million people
following him on Twitter.
Bezos has got 5 million.
That's 20 times more
the influence, same
amount of wealth.
People are starting to realize,
you can be as rich as you want,
but you don't have a voice.
And Elon's teaching you.
You need a voice today,
grab the mic and start
increasing your influence.
Hopefully, can you imagine
if all of a sudden Bezos
comes out and says
the following, like,
think about him.
Imagine Bezos says this.
When Elon said,
honestly, moving forward,
I can't see myself
voting for the left.
I just can't. If a DeSantis
ran, I would vote for him.
Musk said it, Rogan says it.
Imagine if Bezos...
Bill Maher coming out
saying some stuff about,
do you realize how scary
this is for the left?
This is a nightmare for them.
So this is why I
say to you as much
as if you think they're
doing it intentionally, good.
'Cause it's not working.
- Yeah. For the record.
This is Michael Malice who I've
had on the show many times.
Do you know Michael
Malice? Have you have-
- I do. I had him on once.
- Oh, you've had him on.
Yeah, this is, his running
theory for years has been
every time the left
says something crazy,
you just tell people about it,
and they'll just keep
running with the craziness.
So since you just
mentioned DeSantis,
and since we are both
proud Floridians,
let's map something out in
real time and maybe it'll
get to the Governor
or to Donald Trump.
What do you think is gonna
happen with these two?
What do you want to happen?
Because I've been kind of like,
I want DeSantis to stay here,
crush it in the next election,
his gubernatorial election,
obviously in November, and
then see what happens...
But it seems like
Trump's gonna run.
I don't want them to
destroy each other.
It's like, do you,
if you were sitting in a
room with the two of them,
what would you be
telling them right now?
- Okay.
So first of all,
I don't think it's a good idea
if they run simultaneously.
I don't think it is.
I think, I would like to broker
a deal of them two having
a dinner together that
nobody knows about,
including either one of
their administration,
except for like the
main mastermind,
like the main influencers there,
and that's only two voices
and they set up a meeting
and they go and sit
down and talk privately
for a couple hours.
Then maybe the couple of
the advisors are sitting
there and they say, so look,
here's what I wanna do.
Here's what I wanna
do. What's the plan.
Let me ask you a question.
Would you be willing to be a VP?
Um, no. Okay.
So then are you okay
not running this year?
His advisor may say, he's
so hot he has to run.
If he doesn't run, he's missing
out on a great opportunity.
He's young, he's attractive.
America's tired of 70
year old presidents
and maybe America
wants to have a 43, 44,
45 year old president.
And he's peaking.
And sometimes in
situations like this,
you can't assume you're
always gonna peak.
Life doesn't work that way.
You may, five years from now,
the policies may not matter
a lot and he's irrelevant.
Maybe not irrelevant, but
not at the level that he has.
So we think he's gonna
be running. Okay.
So if he runs, then
what are we doing?
Are you gonna call me out?
Are we gonna bash each other?
How are we gonna
win this thing here?
talk to the media?
That's number one step, for me,
it's brokering a sit down
dinner with the two of them
that nobody is aware of,
except from two
parties on each side.
Now, let's say that
doesn't happen. Okay.
All right.
So you heard five
days ago, Trump said,
I would entertain the idea of
him running with me as a VP.
That's a little bit of a dig,
because if I'm DeSantis
and I see this, I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Running with you as a VP?
I could win if I wanted
to run right now.
Now Trump may say, you don't
have a 141 and 11 record,
141 and 11.
My endorsements, added
150 something things,
endorsements, I've given 141.
I have a better record than
the 97-98 bowls is what I got.
You wanna go against that?
So, and then piece that
if they run together,
this will be the last one,
Dave, is if you're putting
the basketball team together,
it makes no sense to have Shaq
and Hakeem on the same team
'cause you got two
fives, it's two centers.
It makes no sense for Kobe
and Jordan to be teammates.
It makes zero sense.
Look, how many of these
super teams they team up
and they don't
win championships,
Boston Celtics, which
they don't really,
Tatum is a superstar,
but not like a crazy.
And they go to the finals
and they play against
Golden State because those
are actual teams, like,
it's shown to you,
teams are winning.
Last year was Milwaukee and
Suns, teams are winning, right?
So I don't know if I like
the Trump and DeSantis
ticket and I don't even believe
DeSantis even believes when
Trump says I would pick him
as a VP, because I think
last minute Trump would flip
and he would take somebody
else and would leave him
out as a VP.
I don't think he would take him
as a VP, because Trump
is gonna do better.
Trump is looking more for a
COO. He's not looking for a CEO.
Mike Pence was a
COO. Santis is a CEO.
So two CEOs as a president
and VP, I don't think
that's a good formula.
- Yeah. It's so interesting.
Well, first off I have to say,
I'm very happy to hear that
clearly you are watching
the Rubin Report
every single day,
because I've been pushing
for the private sit down.
That's been my thing, guys,
just have a private sit down.
I don't know what
you're gonna work out,
but you guys have to work
it out and it doesn't have
to be worked out in
front of all of us.
That's been my main thing.
What I would love to see is
if Trump could sort of be
the king maker here,
if he could clear the
room for DeSantis to run
right through, I think that
probably is the best...
Run the rallies and
make some room, but yes,
your face right there is
what everyone kind of says.
It's like, can he do
that? Would he do that?
I don't know.
- You know would
be a crazy thing?
Here's what's a crazy thing.
If Trump...
This'll never happen.
But if a Trump was able
to have the meeting,
and the VP candidate
becomes his daughter,
so they were to say,
well, why don't you go,
while my daughter's gonna
be the VP and his daughter's
got so much poise and
class and the way she is.
So... An Ivanka-DeSantis ticket.
That's an interesting,
remember the comments
she just made recently
when Ivanka said,
if a bar says that,
then I'll take his word for it.
So she also knows how to
stand up. Like I don't know.
I mean a DeSantis-Trump ticket,
but an Ivanka Trump ticket
sounds very interesting
to some people.
I just throw curve
ball in there.
But I'm just saying that a
lot of ways to map this out.
- Yeah.
You could have been working
for him on The Apprentice.
that's a hell of a
move in the boardroom
at the last second.
Patrick, pleasure
talking to you.
First off, you also
make all the basketball
references that work for me.
We gotta get down here and
shoot sometime. I've been...
- I look forward to-
- Yeah, we're gonna
make that happen.
72 and 10, by the way, those 90,
that was the 96 bulls, right?
72 and 10?
- 72 And 10.
- Not bad, not bad.
- They call them the greatest
basketball team of all time.
Golden State will debate it,
but Jordan said nobody
would've beaten us.
- I don't think anyone
would've beat those balls.
I mean, Jordan just,
he slayed everybody.
He just slayed with six for
six in the finals. Come on.
- Yeah.
That's, by the way,
that debate with LeBron,
I think it's over with.
- Oh, I don't even
think it's a debate.
- It's over with.
- We'll do a separate
show just on old NBA.
I can't do new NBA.
All right, man.
You got two minutes to
stick around for a one more
thing on my, our
Locals community page.
Fantastic.
Patrick Bet-David, links are
down below and we're gonna
do a little something
on Locals right now.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of nonstop yelling, check
out our politics playlists.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.